if somebody is like struggle with like
comparing themselves to somebody how do
you feel about that by understanding
that jealousy and envy is poison all
that energy that you're putting into
being jealous and envious of that person
is time and energy that you could be
putting into actually achieving what you
want it's just so hard for me why I just
feel like it's hard to like see of my
future sometimes when you see everybody
else that's already and that's because
you think the world is scarce yeah
I do nobody else's success is taking
away from your success if you're in real
estate and someone's selling all the
homes in town There's still other homes
to sell in other towns you feel like
this is not some for everybody you're
100 wrong I know you don't know I know
you logically know you're just not
emotional yeah like going to therapy by
like listening to positivity by not
paying attention to their social media
posts and blocking all of them like take
Little Steps first you might have to
block the people that are winning in
your face Maybe in three years after
doing the work you can actually be happy
for them